all right let's go through a couple
things i've been saving up this week and
just didn't really have time for until
today as many of you know we've been
following the supposed bankruptcy of uh
infowars conspiracy theorist alex jones
where he says they don't really have any
money but then they got two one million
dollar bitcoin donations and now they've
got five million but they still don't
have enough money to pay any of the
sandy hook parents in the settlement
that they filed and won against alex
jones for defamation it's all a complete
and total mess alex jones seemed to
almost have like a medical event
almost like stroking out or having a
cardiac event during his show
where he seemed to be saying
they are in a war they i don't know if
these infowars or the american right
wing or who they are in a war and the
only way to win the war
is for you to buy his products including
his supplements and to send him money
this is really full-on stuff it's
simultaneously hilarious
but also extraordinarily weird and
supporting our guest because everybody
we have on is fighting with everything
they've got whoa this is a war against
you and your family of inflation and
collapse it's really like a try decaf
type of moment here
and they know everybody's going to wake
up in the midst of that's why they want
to silence the leaders because they
think they can then defeat you so when
you keep us in the fight you keep
yourself in the fight and this is life
and death right so go to
and get amazing products and sign up for
autoship and continue support make a
donation at the top and go to the stone
defense fund and make a nation to him
because he's a gladiator and a champion
and now they have supplements up on the
screen energy supplements and stuff like
that fight and if you don't support us
you're helping the enemy and i'm not
bitching at lester's i'm telling you
this is all about war roger
well alex i think you're absolutely
right about it yeah alex jones uh agrees
with that globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron and the
rest of these zio beasts
that's my alex jones impression from uh
from from last year
this is absolutely hilarious but also we
really need to make sure that everybody
following the bankruptcy proceedings is
aware of what's going on here you know
this whole like we will only win this
moral war
if you buy my supplements and contribute
to my personal finances
which i claim i don't even have because
i said i'm bankrupt
it it's it it's beyond parody at this
point in time and there is you know even
though alex jones alex jones does kowtow
to religion to some degree but it's not
as overtly a religious show as some
others the supplement stuff it's
starting to remind me of those
evangelical tv shows that sell the food
storage the mad the buckets of food
this is jim baker
offering buckets and it's basically like
a less manic alex jones this is the most
unique
survival food
this is 52 servings right turkey feast
emergency food supply that's right and
this food is 30-year shelf life food it
is even has pump by the way one of the
things i love is that he says it has a
30-year shelf life but at the bottom of
the screen it says it has a 20-year
shelf life it's like sweet so does it
last 20 years or 30 years can pie mousse
for dessert it doesn't mean we made it
the other day it's super delicious
actually i love pumpkin pie pumpkin pie
moose i've never even heard of that it
has honey wheat rolls green bean
casserole like a lot of you make
i have to tell you the green bean
casserole and the pumpkin pie mousse
look basically the same turkey gravy
seasoned stuffing
freeze-dried turkey
the freeze-dried turkey does look like
dog food mashed potatoes
this
for your survival food
this is to have isn't that the best the
apocalypse is coming we are about to be
raptured but you'll be able to enjoy a
completely typical thanksgiving dinner
thanks to my turkey feast survival food
bucket it's the same thing as with the
alex jones segment right it's we're in a
war here and they're trying to silence
you and they're trying to silence me and
the way to fight it
is by buying supplements on my website
it's like a stupidity test i saw a
cartoon with a vending machine
and the vending machine said if you
think the election was rigged insert 100
and it's sort of the same stupidity if
you think alex jones
it's a stupidity test
if you think buying alex jones
supplements will save america
then just send him money and if you pass
the test you get to keep your money it's
really a tragedy of education that
people fall for this stuff in the united
states to the tune of millions of
dollars and as far as the bankruptcy
proceedings with alex jones hopefully
they're paying attention to everything
that's happening with his business
sponsoring today's show is the new book
by jason murchie called wisdom a very
valuable virtue that cannot be bought
this is an excellent book i've been
reading through
no book can really teach you how to be
wise but this is a really well
researched nonfiction book that helps
readers
grow to love the pursuit of wisdom which
is really a process at the end of the
day and if you spend just two minutes
watching my show
you'll know america has a significant
lack of wisdom in many ways republicans
have made an art form out of failing to
think critically
they have their
flexible and exclusive values moral
dogmatism
right now is probably one of the low
points in this particular sense in
american history with trump tribalism
the pandemic and just the the lack of
wise thinking
the author of the book jason murchie
believes that while liberals ought to
aspire to be tolerant and compassionate
right-wing extremism and political
chicanery
must be resisted and overcome and mercy
really brings a refreshing array of
insightful and interesting quotations
and personal reflections it's a
deep and wide investigation into what
wisdom is i've been really enjoying
reading through it it's
really easy to read in chunks
each chapter kind of stands on its own
so you can jump into the book very
quickly it's a book that could have a
really powerful impact on a lot of
readers pick up a copy at
davidpakman.com
wisdom
the link is down below